et puis il faut aussi tenir compte des
marées à venir est de leur importance
celle ci pourrait ou non retardée voire
accélérer le nettoyage des rochers mais
à belle-ile qui fut atteinte par la
marée noire dès les premières semaines
après le naufrage de l'erika
les dégâts sont encore bien visibles
voyez le reportage de claude samper et
christian galley depuis 5 - toutes les
plages de la côte ouest de belle-ile
sont officiellement fermées au public
pourtant ces derniers jours on y
trouvera plusieurs dizaines de
vacanciers qui se moquait éperdument de
l'arrêté d'interdiction à quelques
centaines de mètres d'ici dans chaque
creek 200 militaires toujours sur le
pied de guerre
ici les hommes du 1er régiment de génie
jour après jour il retourne cette petite
plage filtre le sable et passe les
galets au karcher est apparue sap
répondre
pour combien de temps ici là tournoi
retourner tous les cailloux c'est ça il
y en a pour deux mois un peu plus loin
nous rencontrons les hommes de la
première unité de sécurité civile
debout à 6 heures et 8 heures de travail
ensuite à gratter des cailloux au fond
de la trique l'odeur est terrible
aujourd'hui encore ils remontent chaque
jour plus d'une tonne de déchets
arrivent avec la marriott donc là ce
qu'on essaye de faire c'est de ramasser
un maximum de de pétrole avec l'épisode
mais dans les sauts facile que de bacon
sida les gratter sur les rochers à
l'opposé sur la façade est de l'île
les plages sont superbes et ouverte au
public à bord de son catamaran bertrand
préfère promener les touristes de ce
côté nous sommes loin de l'erika loin du
pétrole
les trois mêmes malgré le naufrage
je vous reviendrai absolument oui
et on n'avait pas su qu'il y avait eu
des cas on s'en fera trois fortement
rendu pendre on n'a rien vu pour l'heure
impossible de mesurer l'impact de la
marée noire sur la vie économique de
l'île aucun chiffre officiel n'est
disponible
certains hôtels aurait pourtant des taux
de réservation de -50 % par rapport à
l'été dernier mais à l'office du
tourisme
on reste serein et on souhaite dire la
vérité aux vacanciers faut pas cacher un
faux cachets pour être clair il ya des
plages qui sont propres qui sont
nettoyés d'autres qui sont encore en
cours de nettoyage
pour l'heure seule la clientèle
étrangère et la clientèle haut de gamme
semble bouder ligue 1 le week end
dernier tous les bateaux qui sont
arrivés étaient complets